Hey Youtubers it's Charlie, so a bunch of you guys requested I do I like a recap of
everything that's happened on Game of Thrones so far now would that be like a six hour video
so I'm ready like a super recap from
season 1 to season 4
because the HBO now service is also
available I'm giving away
two iTunes gift cards for like the first
month free
you basically get the first month free
anyway but all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video
but just spoiler warning for everything
on game of thrones so far starting with
Season one
here we go. So for the first season in
had a very much Lannisters versus Starks
motif even though they were
many many great houses in a lot a big
players in the east
we pick up at Winterfell we meet the
Starks we meet the dire wolves
and then we meet the king and his family
of Lannisters, some of them
secret twincest Lannisters. most
notable early WTF
include a teaser for the White Walkers,
quite a way to open the show.
you barely see them big takeaway ice on
Zombies roaming around in the north
and no one believes the Night's Watch
deserter who Ned Stark ends up killing
Totally something going on up there but
they won't really address it for a while
that was way up in the Haunted Forest up
north of Castle black here
Winterfell just a little bit south there
and within the first 20 minutes the
pilot
we meet most the main cast including
Lannisters, Baratheons,
over in the east we meet Daenerys her
brother Viserys and then
Khal Drogo, three very very important
people. The show almost picks up in like
post adventure setting as in like
this huge adventure had happened in
everyone had gone to seed
like that nothing had happened it'd
been a long summer seasons last for
different duration so when people say
winter is coming
it's coming after an extremely long
summer that lasted many many many years
robert baratheon took the throne from the
Targaryens
Daenarys and Viserys over here their
father and has been ruling himself
into his own grave ever sense laying
bastards all over the kingdom
every chance he gets. Ned and Robert are
old friends and Robert had come to
Winterfell
to the Starks home to ask ned to become
his chief adviser, the hand of the King
ned reluctantly accepts and they'll make
their way back to King's Landing down
here
over in the East Daenerys' brother
Viserys is trying to take back the
throne but he needs an army
so he's going to marry Daenerys to Khal
Drogo so that he can get his Khalasar
a forty thousand warriors so back in king's
landing because
ned has become handed the King they
betrothed Ned Stark's own daughter
Sansa stark
to joffrey baratheon and the current heir
to the throne the majority the plot
in kings landing planning in season 1
is all about Ned Stark slowly uncovering
the joffrey is secretly Cersi and Jaime
Lannister's son
a lot of people get killed in the
biggest WTF for the season was Ned Stark
eventually getting his head chopped off
robert died during the season so joffrey
ascended to the throne turns out he's a
monster and
ends up having Ned Stark beheaded thus
begins the war the five kings
which takes us into season two for the
most part for the first couple seasons
game Thrones went from book to book as
one from season to season so
season 2 is mostly book to stuff. Season 2 is all about setting up the idea that
several people
in the Seven Kingdoms feel like they
have a claim to the throne in addition
to obviously Daenerys over in the East
Roberts brother Stannis becomes a major
antagonistic against King's Landing
then theres Robb Stark who becomes Lord of
Winterfell after his father Ned Stark was
beheaded
their so pissed about what happened to
Ned that they declare war
against the Lannisters technically it's
against the throne because they're going
after joffrey they want joffrey's head
so they're mostly going after Lannisters
because they believe the joffrey
is a Lannister even though at this point
it's not common knowledge everyone in
the kingdom isn't saying it out loud
Daenerys in the East has also become a
growing force
at the end of season one she hatched
three new dragons who are believed to
have been gone from the world forever
she takes over Khal Drogos khalaser
but it's slowly falling apart
dragons have a very deep connection to
magic you know no matter what mythology
you're talking about so
the minute they appear on screen it was
a a visual reminder that magic does
exist in this world
so throughout the season you start to
see more evidence a magic
melisandre makes a smoke baby was
one of the big early WTFs in the season
and eventually later we see in army White
Walkers
so you get the sense that there's a greater war going on in the background but most
the main characters don't realize
you have the red God and the great other
the God of the White Walkers
on the other side of that coin most
people in westeros are just worried
about fighting each other the war of the five kinds
stannis a mass an army of ships all
the way up here at dragonstone where he's stationed
takes them to King's Landing and you
have one of the greatest battles
in Game of Thrones history
The Battle of Blackwater the really fun part about the battle is we get the see
Tyrion concoct an elaborate plan using
wildfire
that opens the Alchemy door the game of
Thrones Universe
it really expands the lore in a fun way
wildfire is a lot like Greek fire in the
you can't put it out with water
ill just spread over the top water
everyone almost gets roasted alive
and we get one of the most famous lines
from the show F* the King
just a reminder that loyalty on the show
is fleeting
eventually in the east Daenerys finds
a renewed sense of purpose
as her dragons continue to grow she goes
into a place called the house the undying
and has several visions are things
that may come to pass
or things that may have come to pass at
things in the past been different
the way visions work on Game of Thrones
is very weird sometimes you're seeing
things that might have happened had
things gone differently
and sometimes you're seeing things that
could still happen this is also the
season that we get me the greyjoys in
a much bigger way
they don't appear too often but they're
over here on the Iron Islands reeving and
raping their way all along the coast has
their ancestors did
as we move into season three we see the
war the five kings slowly abating just a
little bit
Robb Stark is that a really good job is
a great battle master
but these are just starting to fall
apart all over the place up in the north
the Greyjoys have taken Winterfell
are Theon Greyjoy in the name of the
Greyjoys. Stannis Baratheon's army has been shattered.
And Tywin Lannister marches back into
King's Landing arguably the most
fearsome and
in all of Westeros. You can also call
the most powerful man
and the richest man although all those things go hand in hand we still think at the Starks
and the Lannisters is like the two big
forces but in this point we meet some of
the other big houses
most notably the Tyrell's aside from the
Lannisters there the other richest house
in Westeros. The Lannisters have their gold mines the Tyrell's have their land they
just have massive amounts of land
up in the north to Jon Snow is running
counterintelligence against the wildlings
another big force the people living
north on the wall he spends most the
season with them
falls in love with Ygritte One of the
best females in the show as you'd expect
things go pretty bad for 'em and he ends up coming back eventually
not before though one of the best visual
effects sequences the shows ever had
the wild things climbing up the wall a
six hundred-foot high
wall of ice you also see like the the
birth of one of the best pairs
of characters on the show Jamie and Brienne
Brienne is trying to help the Starks by
using Jaime Lannister to barter
for ones that are still left in King's
Landing remember the war of the five kings
is still going on so Lannisters
still very much a war with the Starks
then of course we get to probably like
the biggest moment on television that
year
the red wedding if you're not familiar
with the red wedding the name in the
episode is actually the rain to castamere
it's actually been turned into the
Lannister theme so anytime there are
Lannisters on screen you can softly here
the rains of castamere
tune playing in the background the red
wedding refers to an event
whereby the phrase in concert with the
Lannisters
in the throne kill rob stark and pretty
much all of his army at the twins here
at a dinner they had been invited for a
wedding Rob Stark
was supposed to marry one of the Freys
daughters
he derped married someone else for love
pissed the Freys off so the Freys allied
themselves with the Lannisters
and agreed to kill Robb Stark everyone
with them big characters on the show get
killed up all the time but
in the red wedding it was several big
characters all within the span of a
couple minutes of each other
one of the really fun sayings from the show and
from the books is that
the North remembers
so remember even though a lotta Starks
died that day
there's several they're still alive and
will eventually get their revenge
over in the east the Danerys has finally
amassed an army she starts to liberate
slaves
so she's hailed as the mother dragons
because there were three dragons
and as the mother of this big group of
people that she's liberated
it's a fun twist because Targaryens are
typically thought as really fearsome people
and she's being thought of in this
really benevolent way so now we're
moving into season four
in instead of having like you know one
or two really big WTF moment like
climbing the wall or the red wedding
there are several big WTF spread out
throughout the season
we also get to meet one of the most
interesting characters the shows ever had
Oberyn Martell here their from the south
Dorne a place that we haven't seen yet
House Martell in an interesting twist are
bitter enemies of
House Lannister we don't really explore that too much until the end of the season
Oberyn Martell is trying to solve the
mystery at his sister's murder
she was wife of rhaegar targaryen who
was killed during
Robert's rebellion he finds out that the
man who killed her is the Mountain here
the champion of Tywin Lannister he wants
to kill a bunch of people
most notably Lannisters but the
Mountain ends up becoming the first person
on the list
Oberyn Martell verses Gregor Clegane
probably the best fights all season
they fought in a trial by combat by way
of the purple wedding
that's another red wedding level event
and the interesting thing that the show
didn't convey is that
in the timeline of the books it actually
happen relatively close
to the Red Wedding it was almost like
George RR Martin was trying to help the
fans out
he killed all these amazing star
characters that everyone loves so much
any had to answer it by killing of
joffrey Lannister
even though Starks had absolutely
nothing to do with it for that we have
to thank the queen of thorns
working with little finger so joffrey
dies Tyrion gets blamed and thrown into black cells
and that leading to trial by combat
Oberyon becomes Tryion's champion
that's how we got in a fight with the
Mountain
he loses so that means the Tryion is going
to be executed
but he is rescued by his brother working
with Varys
instead of going straight out he
actually goes up to his father's
chambers
you gonna try kills father find his
longtime lover Shae in his bed
ends up killing them both Shae was really
sad that even if you didn't like the
character
but him killing Tywin on the shitter
was probably one of the most fun deaths
all season
and a huge WTF so as the story is moving along things keep growing and growing up
at the Wall we have
and army Wildlings that are marching on
the Wall, marchin on Castle Black
at the Battle reaches its epic climax
Stannis comes riding in
with the new army of Sellswords that
he's acquired they make quick work at
the Wildlings who surrender
so we're left with a buncha characters
that are gonna try and figure out what
to do after this big battle
at the start a season 5 over in the East
Daenerys has now used her Army
to take control one of the biggest
cities in the area Meeren.
she finds out that there's a big
difference between liberating a group of people
and ruling them in a very effective way
is that what do you do
after the battle is done what does it
mean to be a real Queen
and by the time her dragons are so big
that they become a huge problem
they start eating people so she is forced
to lock
two of them up. The other one Drogon
is flying around a free will
he can be captured so he literally
continues to become
a bigger and bigger problem physically
and metaphorically
so that brings us this season five we're
gonna see like a couple really big new
places new locations
and a new big family that we have met
you
The Martell's are one of the most powerful
families in Westeros
that show hasn't done a lot with yet. We saw Oberyon Martell in season four
but he was just like the tip of the
iceberg then bringing Dorne into the story
required them to go to a whole new
filming location
It just looks vastly diverse from what
we've seen before
through through one of the most fun things
is that from season to season
all the Alliance's change so characters
that were best friends in one season
hate each other in the next you know
just because Tryion is a Lannister
doesn't mean that his family isn't guning
for him still after the death joffrey
in the background to we still have the
White Walkers and the Red god they're
going to continue to be a really big
thing
especially up at this other new location
Heart Home be very excited for special
white walker stuff to happen
up here so what I'm probably going to do next is do a deep dive into a group characters like
the Martel's
or maybe Arya Stark that'll probably post on
Saturday like in between Daredevil videos
be sure to subscribe to get that I'll
announce the winners of the HBO now give
away whenever I post that
just in case you're finding me for the
first time what I'm gonna do on Sunday for
the premiere
is do a new bonus video early in the
day and then I'll post my episode review
after episode 1 airs
when that episode post the giveaway for
that video is going to be two sign copies
up a feast for crows and a dance of dragons
both signed by George RR Martin
and I'll ship them anywhere in the world so it
doesn't
matter it opened international people
after that week to week to give away
will just be either Amazon gift cards or
HBO now subscriptions just depending
on your preferences
so you guys have any questions about
about the giveaways or have any request
for both videos week to week cuz I will
do bonus videos every week
just be sure to leave them in the
comments it's gonna be really fun season
there will be a lot of changes
from the books so as I do my episode
reviews are trying to explain what is
different from the books whenever it
happens
if you had the HBO now service you can
also you can watch
every single episode of game Thrones on
demand just like Netflix while you guys wait for
my next Game of Thrones bonus video and for Daredevil to drop
you can click here for all my other season 5
videos I just did a Sansa video
and you can click here for might non-spoilery daredevil episode 1 review
so that's all dropping at midnight get
excited everybody lets high five
I'll see you guys in little bit.